nachdem man den deutschen seit Jahren
alles mögliche verbieten will vom
Autofahren über das Fliegen und das
Fleisch essen will man uns jetzt also im
Gegenzug die Drogen legalisieren
ganze zwei Jahre hat man uns im Namen
der Bürgerrechte sogar die
im Namen des Gesundheitsschutz die
Bürgerrechte weggenommen und jetzt will
man uns also im Gegenzug Drogen zur
Beruhigung geben ich glaube das Kiffen
nicht harmlos ist ich bin Mutter von
vier Kindern und ich habe schon vor 30
Jahren in meinem eigenen Freundeskreis
gesehen wie Cannabis die Einstiegsdroge
war und später Kokain oder eben auch
synthetische Drogen zu nehmen Lauterbach
behauptet nun es führe zu einem besseren
Gesundheits- und Jugendschutz wörtlich
sagte er das Gesetz wird auch den Konsum
insbesondere bei jungen Menschen
reduzieren bessere Gesundheit und
weniger Konsum sind das Ziel auch der
Justizminister Buschmann sagt die
Legalisierung bedeutet eine bessere
Produktqualität also besseres Hasch ich
bin gespannt ob er sich demnächst auch
um reineres Heroin oder auch um
kristallkarre klares Koks für die
deutschen bemühen wird das Gesetz wird
ein kaum kontrollierbares
Bürokratiemonster werden der
Schwarzmarkt den man angeblich bekämpfen
wird wird auch bleiben wir haben die
Beispiele in Kanada und auch in
Kalifornien wo der Schwarzmarkt
weiterhin floriert die
Polizeigewerkschaften waren die
Apotheken warnen die Fachärzte warnen
trotzdem möchte unsere Regierung hier
weitermachen und logisch ist das ganze
eigentlich auch nicht denn wer eine
Droge legalisiert der schafft den Markt
nicht ab sondern pusht ihn sogar nach
oben
sehr steile These Frau Kelle wir haben
direkt mal was vorbereitet für sie nicht
nur für sie eigentlich für alle aber
erstmal für sie schauen Sie mal hier wir
haben auf der einen Seite man schönes
Glas Rotwein ich trinke Weißwein
wir hätten auch Weißwein nehmen können
es ist ein Symbol weil so und wir haben
hier noch ein weiteres Symbol wir haben
einen schönen joint wenn man das jetzt
mal einfach nebeneinander legt was ist
für Sie der große Unterschied
der große Unterschied ist für mich dass
das legal ist und das illegal ist weil
es auch durchaus einen Grund gibt warum
ist das
illegal und das legal
grundsätzlich kann man sagen irgendwie
weil das Gesetz so gemacht worden ist
zweitens weil das eine Droge ist die
unkalkulierbar ist und im übrigen auch
sehr schwer dosierbar ist also die ich
habe auch mal gekifft als ich
Jugendliche war und fast dann so wie
fast alle das wahrscheinlich einmal auch
mal ausprobiert haben
das ist das ist etwas was die
Gehirnstruktur verändern kann was ihnen
auch Fachärzte bei Jugendlichen ja aber
auch bei Erwachsenen es ist ja nicht so
also es ist ja so dass sehr viele auch
darauf hängen bleiben und dass es vor
allen Dingen auch die Hemmschwelle und
das wissen wir leider auch die
Hemmschwelle senkt auch Sommer stärkere
Drogen zu sich zu nehmen das halte ich
im Übrigen für die gefährlichste das
gefährlichste Problem in dieser Sache
das ist ja eben nicht nur sozusagen um
die Tüte geht die man ab und zu mal
raucht sondern das ist das der Effekt
ganz offensichtlich sichtbar ist bei
vielen und ich kenne wie gesagt allein
in meinem persönlichen Umfeld einige
also Eltern deren Kinder quasi auf den
Drogen hängen geblieben sind in meiner
Jugend hatte ich mehrere in meiner
Clique auch die umgestiegen sind weil es
sozusagen irgendwann reicht das nicht
mehr und irgendwann braucht man etwas
stärkeres aber sind das hat man vom Kern
kam und haben die nicht auch Alkohol
getrunken könnte nicht Alkohol genauso
eine Einstiegsdroge sein ist Alkohol
nicht auch genauso gefährlich für
Jugendliche Gehirne für die Entwicklung
ja deswegen sind sie auch bei
Jugendlichen verboten im übrigen genau
aber das soll ja also Karl Lauterbach
ja es soll für Erwachsene sein insofern
finde ich das auch sehr erstaunlich aber
die wir wissen natürlich auch dass
dieses das ist nur für Erwachsene und
für Kinder erst ab 18 wird ja nicht
funktionieren sie glauben doch nicht
dass es keine dass die Jugendlichen sich
das nicht beschaffen der Unterschied
wird jetzt sein dass der 18-Jährige der
für seine Minderjährigen Freunde das
ganze kauft das ganze jetzt auch noch
legal besorgen kann also ich finde dass
Signal fatal bleiben wir aber mal bei
den Erwachsenen ja darum die zu
entkriminalisieren Menschen die einfach
genauso wie sie abends gerne mal an Glas
Wein trinken sagen nee Alkohol ist jetzt
eher nicht meins ich trinke zum erzeugt
aber zur Entspannung ziehe ich einfach
mal am Joint warum sind diese Menschen
Kriminelle und die anderen nicht
im Moment sind sie so weil das Gesetz
ist so regelt ich halte es allerdings
auch die Frage wir können ja die Frage
auch ausweiten warum verbieten wir
irgendwie Ecstasy also ich kenne auch
Leute die sagen wieso Extasy habe ich
während meiner Prüfung genommen hat
super gewirkt es gibt auch andere
Aufputschmittel die sie bleiben Rezept
gibt also wie ich sagen wir können wir
könnten sie könnten
also es gibt aber
ja ist nicht dasselbe aber es ist wir
sehen Sie das sie glauben sie dass
Alkohol und kiffen was völlig anderes
sind dass man die völlig anders
behandeln sollte also wenn es nicht
anders wäre dann würden die Strafen ja
nicht so hoch sein also als
Richter bzw als Schöffe gerade in Kleve
habe ich sehr oft mit solchen Fällen zu
tun wo dann halt mit welchen Fällen
genau ja also mit drogenfällen die dann
halt von Holland oder Niederlanden
sozusagen nach Deutschland sozusagen
transportiert werden und wenn ich dann
überlege allein für die für den
Transport ja von von 30 Gramm oder wird
schon ein paar Jahre Leben und die
Gesetzesmacher die haben sicherlich sich
was dabei gedacht das jetzt sozusagen
von heute auf morgen so völlig zu
legalisieren finde ich zum einen aus
Gesundheitsaspekten also da stimme ich
Frau Kerle zu aber auch sozusagen aus
dem Signal wie man der Bevölkerung das
jetzt irgendwie erklären will dass man
also quasi führen für ein Kurierdienst
im Jahr sechs Jahre Strafe gibt und
jetzt auf einmal soll das jetzt sagen
also frei sein also ich bin kein kein
überzeugter zu klauen ist auch verboten
ist zu verkaufen oder ist zu fahren
natürlich nicht
ja das ist klar aber die sozusagen also
die diese Menge
zu konsumieren oder zu kaufen also
kommen wir auf das will ja keiner Ändern
der Aspekt also eine der Hauptbegründung
ist ja dass man sagt irgendwie die es
haben nicht es habe nicht zu einem
geringeren Drogenkonsum geführt dass es
verboten ist also man sagt verbote
bringen nichts wer legalisieren und
Regeln sozusagen und wir bauen damit den
Schwarzmarkt angeblich und
kriminalisieren ich glaube das ist einer
der Hauptpunkte zu sagen dass normale
Erwachsenen werden zwei zentrale
Begründungen waren bessere
Gesundheitsschutz und Jugendschutz ja
also wie man durch die Legalisierung
einer Droge Jugendschutz betreibt ist
mir wirklich ein Rätsel und der
Schwarzmarkt das ist eine ein großes
eine große Begründung ist man wolle den
Schwarzmarkt sozusagen abbauen ja wann
muss doch einfach mal schauen was in der
Welt passiert irgendwie in diesen
Ländern in Kanada hat hat es nicht dazu
geführt dass der Schwarzmarkt abgebaut
wurde im Gegenteil der ist irgendwie
etwa dreimal so groß wie der legale
Markt warum weil natürlich das Hasch auf
dem Schwarzmarkt nach wie vor deutlich
günstiger ist als in den lizenzierten
Shops also läuft das weiter in
Kalifornien derselbe Effekt auch da
schätzt man das zum Beispiel etwa die
die illegalen Felder zum Anbau etwa 10
also eine 10 Mal so große Fläche
einnehmen wie die legalen Felder das
heißt dieses Argument ist nicht da ja
gerne also
vielleicht sozusagen die
Lebenswirklichkeit haben spricht so ein
bisschen dagegen wir haben ich sitze
regelmäßig mit Freunden zusammen die
einen haben so was in der Hand der
anderen trinken Rotwein ich gehört ja
zur rotweinfraktion und ich muss sagen
wer ich wenn ich am nächsten Morgen
aufwache bin ich derjenige der in
Schädel habe den geht es meistens gut
also das vielleicht nur als als Evidenz
nein aber dahinter meine ich steckt
etwas ganz ernsthaftes wir wollen keinen
Verbotsstaat sein wir wollen doch
eigentlich ein Land sein wo wir den
Menschen zutrauen dass sie frei
entscheiden dass sie auch über ihre
Gesundheit frei entscheiden dürfen und
ich meine dass jede Regelung die am Ende
zu einem zu weniger Regulierung führt
erstmal einen Schritt in die richtige
Richtung ist und ich glaube man kann die
Menschen das Zutrauen man kann den
Menschen vertrauen und sagen ihr wisst
schon welche Dosis richtig für euch ist
es kommt darauf an dass ihr euch nicht
sinnlos betrinkt in dich sinnlos zu
kifft nicht zu schnell Autofahrt oder
einfach nicht immer übertreibt aber
dieses Grund Vertrauen in die Menschen
die finde das sollten wir haben und das
ist ein außerordentlich liberativ
liberale Ansatz ganz spannender Punkt
weil das ganze kommt ja nun gerade von
Karl Lauterbach unserem
Gesundheitsminister beim Thema Corona
sehr respektiv auf der anderen Seite
jetzt aber doch mal ein Versuch
Eigenverantwortung zuzulassen umgesetzt
was im Koalitionsvertrag statt und dort
ist es hineingekommen nicht auf auf
Ansehen der SPD sondern damals auch
einen der Grünen und der FDP ja also und
Lauterbach vollzieht jetzt etwas die SPD
war eigentlich im Koalitionsvertrag weil
die noch so ein bisschen hin und ich
wollte ich wollte nur auf die
Eigenverantwortung hinaus auf das Thema
Eigenverantwortung dass er sehr viel
dafür angefeindet wurde beim Thema
Corona ja das heißt okay Gegenteil man
hat gerade in der corona-zeit hat sich
ja gezeigt dass die Frage des also der
persönlichen Einstellung zur Frage des
persönlichen Risikos und der
Eigenverantwortung komplett abgeschafft
worden ist und man uns ständig quasi
erklärt hat wir könnten nicht für unsere
eigene Gesundheit sorgen genau und und
wir müssten qu die zwangsweise vom Staat
die Regeln übernehmen
ich bin grundsätzlich bei Ihnen nur dann
sage ich okay dann müssen wir das aber
auch ausweiten und ich habe dann
allerdings immer noch eine Schwierigkeit
weil die Frage ist wo hören wir dann zum
Beispiel auf also wir sagen mit mit
dieser Argumentation dass man sagt wir
vertrauen darauf dass die Leute ihren
Gesundheitsschutz selber ernst nehmen
müssen müssen wir dann alle nicht
eigentlich alle Drogen nach dieser
Regelung freigeben also nach dem Motto
was geht es mich denn an irgendwie wenn
ein anderer sagt ich möchte aber nicht
rauchen sondern ich nehme immer diese
Pillen die Vertrag ich besser oder die
finde ich toll oder ich nehme ich nehme
Crystal oder der anderen nimmt sonst was
ja also die Frage also irgendwo wenn man
zu anfängt so als so zu argumentieren
muss man natürlich auch schauen irgendwo
muss man ja trotzdem wieder einsetzen ne
und es gibt dann genau wir müssen immer
irgendwo Grenzen setzen weil es gibt
natürlich auch selbst schädigendes
Verhalten wo man sagt das können wir als
Gesellschaft eigentlich gar nicht
hinnehmen zumal die Gesellschaft ja die
Folgekosten trägt also jeder der sich
zuballert und und krank wird dauerhaft
krank wird oder Schäden verursacht für
die Zahlen wir ja insofern irgendwie ist
das schon können wir das nicht einfach
so freigeben mal aus ihrer Sicht Herr
peruanovic sie sind der jüngste jetzt
hier in der Runde so in ihrem Kreis
haben Sie das Gefühl dass ich dazu
geballert wird mit Kiffen und ob es ein
Unterschied machen würde ob es legal ist
oder nicht geht es da eher um
Entkriminalisierung oder sagt man ja
endlich kann ich alles machen was ich
will und jetzt kann ich mich richtig
darüber zu hauen nein also in meinem
Freundeskreis wird tatsächlich sich mehr
die Rübe zugeballert mit Alkohol
tatsächlich ja das ist wirklich
überhaupt kein Problem Bewusstsein da
dass das sind irgendeiner Form schädlich
ist das ist ein Thema ist es immer noch
ein Thema das also
das ist kein Thema mehr aber
ich war nie der große Konsument von
Drogen aber beim Alkohol ist es ja genau
das Gegenteil der wird sogar das ja
abgekühltet irgendwo ne wir haben das
beim Oktoberfest gesehen da biedern sich
auch Politiker an
mit Alkohol da fließt der Alkohol in
Strömen und was dort passiert das ist ja
eines eines zivilisierten Landes in
Deutschland sind alle Parteien dabei
genau das sind alle Parteien dabei und
ich finde diesen Vergleich den sie
aufgetan haben auch sehr gut weil ich
finde es richtig dass man über die
Gesundheitsrisiken von Cannabis spricht
die gibt es ja auch in meinem
Freundeskreis oder ehemaligen
Bekanntenkreis gibt es Leute die
nachhaltige Schäden davon getragen haben
tatsächlich aber bei dem Alkohol ist das
natürlich ja auch der Fall und wenn ich
vielleicht eine Anekdote erzählen kann
ich habe drei Jahre in den Niederlanden
gelebt dann ist es ja seit sehr langer
Zeit legal und da gehst du in den
Coffeeshop dort kaufst du das und mein
Eindruck ist dass für die Holländer für
die Niederlande selber also meine
Studentengruppe für die hat das
überhaupt keine Rolle mehr gespielt das
waren vor allem die deutschen Touristen
die dann in die Niederlande gegangen
sind um dort in den Coffeeshops sich die
Sachen zu holen also ich glaube man
könnte auch eine gewisse Entzauberung
vollziehen wenn man Cannabis jetzt
legalisieren würde gibt es Menschen in
Ihrem Umkreis wo man sagen die kiffen
sich das Leben einfach auch ein bisschen
schön es ist ganz schön hart hier und
man kann auch einfach mal sagen ja warum
nicht das hilft mir zu entspannen das
hilft mir auch einfach mal ein bisschen
abzuschalten und einfach mal zu sagen
sind wir gerade sein lassen
ich kannte so Leute tatsächlich ja jetzt
hat sich vielleicht auch harmonisch mein
Freundeskreis ein bisschen so da
differenziert dass nicht mehr die Kiffer
dabei sind wie gesagt das ist mehr der
Alkohol aber ja ein guter Freund von mir
von der Schule ja hat hadert immer noch
tatsächlich damit und das ist mir so ein
Gedächtnis geblieben weshalb ich jetzt
auch nicht sagen würde dass das alles
kein Problem ist und so aber haben wir
tatsächlich ein größeres Problem mit
Alkohol oder haben wir ein größeres
Problem mit Drogen mit anderen Drogen
vielleicht noch haben sie zahlen also
vielleicht nur mal so als aus meiner
Praxis jetzt was ich so mitbekommen also
die meisten fangen natürlich mit
Cannabis an und dann kommen dann später
die härteren Drogen und wenn das
legalisiert wird dann wird das ja
sozusagen dann hat man die Auswahl
zwischen Alkohol Cannabis und dann
natürlich die härteren und ich kenne
sehr viele Fälle so die dann je nach
sozusagen Veranstaltungen oder je nach
sozusagen anders unterschiedliche Drogen
konsumieren und jetzt mit der
Legalisierung gerade jetzt auch in der
jetzigen Phase so also wir wirklich an
vielen verbots- und regulierungs also
bis hin ins Wohnzimmer den Regulator auf
18 Grad stellen wollen dann kommt man
mit so einer mit so einer
pseudo-liberalen sozusagen Idee wo man
das das kommt auch nicht sehr
authentisch und ehrlich bei der
Gesellschaft an ja also ich kann nicht
auf der einen Seite sozusagen sagen Sie
haben noch nicht mehr es ist nicht in
der Lage die Maske selber zu tragen aber
sie dürfen sozusagen jetzt Cannabis noch
und dürfen die auch zu Hause sozusagen
züchten ja also ich meine der ganze
bürokratieapparat der dahinter dass die
Kontrollen die ganzen Möglichkeiten das
ist ja das ist ja das muss man ja
berücksichtigen dieses Gesetz sieht ja
ein offenbar vor dass man 30 Gramm haben
und drei Pflanzen stellen Sie sich mal
vor die eine ist halbwegs sie wollen
eine neue kaufen dürfen sie das haben
sie dreieinhalb viel spannender finde
ich noch mal die Frage nach den THC
Obergrenzen da wäre ich dann tatsächlich
bei Ihnen also für Jugendliche das dann
zu kontrollieren da frage ich mich wie
man das machen möchtet also es gibt
viele Bereiche wo man wo man sich fragt
irgendwie zum Beispiel dein Auto fahren
also beim Alkohol hätten wir jetzt aber
mal haben wir eine Promillegrenze
irgendwann festgelegt ich bin der ich
bin sehr gespannt wie das wie das
eigentlich beim Kiffen dann laufen soll
das sind ja auch solche Dinge irgendwie
kann ich dann bekifft fahren darf die
Polizei mich überhaupt noch
kontrollieren weil es ist ja dann etwas
legales also wenn ich Auto fahre bin ich
ja schon 18 darf ich also legal kiffen
aber darf ich dann damit Auto fahren
gibt es irgendwelche Grenzwerte auch der
Zoll also die Polizei Gewerkschaft sagt
das gibt ein riesen Aufgabenfeld für den
Zoll auch weil das wird ja zu einer Ware
die versteuert werden muss also wir
versteuern dann Drogen in Deutschland da
sind wir tatsächlich schon mal bei einem
sehr guten Punkt in die Nummer
ansprechen wollte können wir es uns
tatsächlich überhaupt leisten auf solche
Steuereinnahmen zu verzichten wir sind
in einer größter Erde der größten Krisen
die wir je gesehen haben die Menschen
haben Existenzängste damit könnten wir
mal so richtig ordentlich Herr Lindner
was in die Kasse spüren das bringt eine
ganze Menge also Alkohol oder überhaupt
Steuern auf Genussmittel um darauf will
auch Herr Lindner sicherlich nicht
verzichten es gibt noch den anderen
Aspekt man kann natürlich auch prima in
Cannabis vom Anlegen also es gab mal
einen wahren Sinn
in Cannabis vom Land und das ist ganz
gut gelaufen also wer das in den letzten
fünf Jahren gemacht hat der ist nicht
ganz schlecht gefahren
also es ist auch eine finanzielle Macht
dahinter gut das könnte man aber zynisch
sagen dass also der Staat die Geschäfte
der Drogendealer jetzt gerne in die
eigene Kasse lieber spülen möchte gut
aber es kommt in eine Kasse ne und wir
haben uns dann super also dann dann
bauen wir jetzt Kindergärten aus
Drogengeld besser als keine Kindergärten
zu bauen vielleicht ja wieso also das
ist das ist Drogengeld und das
Alkoholsteuer ist kein Drogengeld ich
finde gerade auch keine Zigaretten ist
auch da hattet wenn bei einer Zigaretten
steuert da beschwert sich jetzt auch
keiner drüber dass wir damit Geld
einnehmen man sagt schon doch wir retten
rauchen aber sie würde mich über viele
Steuern gerne beschweren in diesem Land
aber ich glaube das ist der falsche Weg
ist sozusagen um Steuer ein neue
Steuereinnahmen sich auszudenken jetzt
quasi ins Geschäft einzusteigen finde
ich schon eine ziemlich steile These gut
also ich glaube wir beenden das
kifferthema an dieser